this conference is being recorded
30 seconds 10 seconds
my assumption is
okay heads up
good morning everyone welcome to the
parliamentary precinct in downtown
ottawa i'm chris rantz the moderator
with parliamentary press gallery
executive we have with us four people
for our briefing today uh jean-yves
duclos who's just being seated there the
federal minister of health in moncton
new brunswick we have the honorable
dominic leblanc he's the minister of
intergovernmental affairs and virtually
in greater ottawa we have the canada's
chief public health officer dr teresa
tam and dr howard knew her deputy
this press conference will last an
update last about 60 minutes uh if mr
duclow would begin please good to see
you sir
i
would be minister leblanc first
so uh merci merced
thank you very much good morning
everyone
uh across the country we're seeing an
increase in daily
covet 19 cases
the new variant once again signals our
need to be vigilant and continue to
follow public health guidelines in order
to reduce the spread of the virus
we've been doing since this is
a premium
is having a major impact
on the day-to-day lives of canadians
and i can assure all of you that our
government will continue to use the
resources we have to support provinces
and territories as they deliver care in
their communities to the extent possible
minister bill blair my colleague
minister bill blair
and communities
campaigns the federal government will
continue million vaccinations
and a record number
testing we anticipate increasing
requests for assistance from provinces
and territories
in the coming weeks
while we while we will do everything we
can to respond it's important to
remember that health care ultimately
is a provincial and territorial
jurisdiction
and we as a government have to
efficiently use the federal resources we
can bring to bear
to fill the gaps that provinces and
territories are identifying
we will be speaking with all of canada's
premiers early next week to discuss the
changing realities we are seeing and how
we can continue to work collaboratively
to keep canadians safe
at a time when our health care system is
under stress
mr o'toole
is encouraging people to do things that
are adding to that pressure and that
will continue to put canadians
and our health care workers
at increased risk
almost two years into this pandemic
it's hard to believe that mr o'toole
still doesn't get it
vaccines work
and vaccines are the best way
out of this pandemic that's why we put
in place
mandatory vaccine requirements for
federally regulated workplaces
and for people wanting to travel
by airplane
or train
but mr o'toole won't support these
requirements
and he won't even ensure
that his own members of parliament and
senators are vaccinated
his lack of leadership would only force
more lockdowns and put canadians
at greater risk
success
rather than to
supporting people who are doing the
right thing
which would protect workers
once again
more focused on his own job
and appeasing members of his own party
than supporting canada's healthcare
workers on top of that
he opposed supports for people who are
doing the right thing
like keeping their workers connected to
their jobs
through the federal wage subsidy
our priority has been and will always
continue to be
working collaboratively to keep
canadians safe
thank you very much and i would like to
give the floor to my colleague
merci
about the how the government of canada
is working with the provinces and
territories to ensure that canada has
the tools it needs to cut the spread of
the omicron variant
on wednesday the prime minister and i
announced that the government of canada
will deliver an additional
140 million rapid antigen tests to
provinces and territories this month
metro z on wednesday
on a per capita
already beginning to be delivered which
will be delivered to provinces and
territories on a per capita basis or
already beginning to be delivered
rapid antigen tests are an important
tool to empower and empower individual
canadians to cut the spread of the
omicron variant
these tests enable canadians to validate
their symptoms and take personal action
to isolate and reduce reduce the risk to
others rapid tests remain
a first vital
line of defense in helping to identify
and therefore to reduce the spread
throughout the country
le tesco
personal
and reduce
yesterday i met with my colleagues from
provinces and territories health
ministers to discuss what collectively
we are doing to shore up our defenses
against umicron i want to thank all of
my colleagues from all provinces and
territories for our conversations
yesterday
and more importantly for our and their
continuing hard work and difficult
decisions during this crisis and for
their unwavering commitment to the
health of all canadians
together we will continue to protect
canadians and manage through the
challenges of this new omicron variant
for the federal government that includes
securing access to
leading edge drugs and treatments
including anti-viral treatments
as you know we have already signed and
secured agreements with both merck and
pfizer to supply canada with oral
anti-viral drugs i will have more to say
about those drugs and about health
canada's approval process in the coming
weeks
yeah
during this crisis
as you
know we have already signed agreements
with mark
and this happened in december
these companies will supply canada
with oral general antiviral portions
about
more broadly
getting vaccinated wearing a mask and
taking
personal health precautions continued
continue to be the best way to stop the
spread of kovis 19 in our communities
every canadian every one of us has a
role to play and the vast majority of us
have stepped up to do our part to date
77
of all canadians of all ages have been
fully vaccinated
right now provinces and territories are
rapidly rolling out booster campaigns
and more than 8.6 million booster shots
have already been administered across
the country
i'm also pleased to report that there
will be enough doses of the vaccine to
give all kids age 5 to 11
2 doses by the end of this month
if you haven't already done so i
encourage you to roll up your sleeves
and get that first second or third shot
as the prime minister said just
wednesday
it is never too late to do the right
thing
i personally got my booster shot just
yesterday and i'm happy to say it was
moderna
indeed both moderna and pfizer are solid
efficient and safe mrna vaccines
i allow myself to repeat it
but we need
canadians of all ages
have already been admitted
it is never too late to do the right
thing
this is obviously a difficult and
uncertain time
what we choose to do now will determine
our very short-term future the
government of canada will be there and
is there to support you in your
communities and you colleagues and
provinces and territories as we work
together to finish this fight against
kobe 19.
is
and we have the tools to do it so let's
continue to exercise prudence and
caution and take care of each other
give the floor to dr tam
siemens
thank you
since the last epidemiology update prior
to the holidays covert 19 cases have
continued to accelerate rapidly with
omicron now predominating and widespread
across much of the country
nationally the average daily case count
has increased by 65 percent compared to
the previous week with an average of
close to 42 000 cases being reported
daily over the last seven days up to
january the fifth although very high
infection rates have challenged testing
capacities in many areas of the country
which will unless as underestimate
few case numbers we continue to test and
sequence at very high levels to track
the spread of the virus as well as
monitor variant predominance
at the same time we're using multiple
other indicators such as laboratory
tests positivity and hospitalization
trends that continue to be very useful
for monitoring overall disease activity
and severity respectively
currently these trends are all
increasing as a result of the sheer
number of cases occurring with this
rapidly spreading variant
for the most recent seven day period
laboratory testing positivity is
estimated at 29
indicating significant community
transmission
although evidence from ongoing
surveillance and recent studies
indicates that this risk of
hospitalization is lower for omicron
compared to delta the sudden
acceleration of omicron an enormous
volume of cases is driving severe
illness trends
given current daily case counts are
already about 400 percent higher than
the peak of the third wave it is not
unexpected to see daily hospitalizations
rising
however international surveillance
suggests that while these trends can be
expected to increase with the omicron
surge severe illnesses are not rising at
the same explosive rate as for cases
presently in canada over the past week
an average of close to 3
650 people with covert 19 were being
treated in their hospitals each day
with almost 600 in intensive care units
represent
i think weekly increases of 91
and 25 respectively
during the same period there were on
average 39 deaths reported each day
currently we still need millions more
canadians increase their protection with
covert 19 vaccines including almost 7
million eligible people who neither
first or second those of their primary
series
as well many others are eligible to get
a boosted dose to help restore
protection that may have waned since
their second dose moreover there is
accumulating evidence a boosted dose
results in better protection against
severe illness including against the
omicron variant that appears to have a
higher degree of immune invasion
boosted doses are particularly important
for certain groups such as healthcare
workers and those at highest risk of
severe illness from covert 19
including older adults people with high
risk medical conditions
and people in and from indigenous
communities
either fisa biontech or moderna mrna
vaccines are effective as boosters so
please feel confident in accepting
whichever vaccine is offered to you
as public health authorities continue
with vaccination efforts while closely
monitoring local epidemiology for signs
of peaking activity in the weeks to come
we can all help by reducing our contacts
to get us through this difficult time
that much faster practically speaking we
need to continue to get fully vaccinated
and receive a boosted dose when eligible
limit in-person contacts to immediate
household members as much as possible
and consistently use layers of personal
protection to reduce the risk of
exposure and spreading the virus
including wearing a good quality and
snug fitting face mask
maintaining good ventilation and
following local public health advice
this might feel like a double marathon
that we didn't sign up for
but despite feeling tired we should have
a sense of achievement for the ground
we've covered so far for staying on
track and knowing we can still draw
strength from each other to get where we
need to go
thank you merci
meg
thank you doctor
twist
hello everyone
is
daily over the latest
multiple other indicators
activity and severity respectively
actually
compared to delta
international surveillance suggests that
while these trends
over the last
week of
1500 people 19 were being treated in our
hospitals
a weekly
with covert 19 vaccines
including the almost seven million
eligible people who need it
second dose of their prominent primary
seriousness
as well many other eligible people are
ineligible
mrna vaccines are particularly important
for surgery
such as healthcare workers and those at
highest risk of severe illnesses
people with high risk medical conditions
we can all help
by reducing our contacts no contact
offended
through this difficult time
of
while maintaining good ventilation
thank you dr new we have 36 minutes for
questions and answers we'll be going to
the phones for the first section uh
and with one question one follow-up the
final 10 minutes will be for the
reporters in the room operator would you
please begin please and a reminder if uh
the questioners and the people answering
could keep everything succinct so we can
get through more people please go ahead
operator
thank you merci you may press star one
if you have a question perhaps you serve
it
um
[Music]
do you know if deliveries will be the
same amount uh
as quickly as possible
i understand
that my colleagues throughout the
country are looking for more
predictability
i've spoken with my staff and i'm
working with the minister
of procurement
yesterday we started a discussion that
will continue in the next days and weeks
regarding the
distribution strategy
we have three main objectives the first
is of course
these tests
obviously public health objectives
the second is to be
efficient we want these
to maintain our economy
the third objective is to be equitable
we want to make sure that these tests
are delivered
to those people who need it
need them the most knowing that we'll
also always have a scarcity of these
tests in short and
according
the holidays minister freeland said that
we had enough for everyone so do you
have an answer to explain why people in
your own writing aren't able to get
their hands on it
well before december
found that there was very little demand
for rapid tests throughout the country
this isn't
pointing the finger at anybody it's just
a statement of fact
things changed in early december with
the arrival of the holidays we knew that
people were going to see more people so
provinces and territories
advised us that there was a higher
demand for rapid tests
in december we received five times
we found that
140 million tests which is four times
more than what was delivered in december
which was five times more than what was
delivered in the months
very quickly
especially considering that worldwide
supply chain chains are very
fragile with
daily with our suppliers to make sure
that we have the amounts of tests
delivered per the deadline
operator next question thank you
thank you merci the next question is
from ryan turmelty from the national
post please go ahead
yeah hi um my first question is for
minister duklow
dr tam before the christmas break
released her annual report calling it a
vision to transform canada's public
health system
uh calls for a lot of changes uh more
data more workers that sort of thing
i'm wondering if you support this vision
if your government's going to be acting
on it
yes three
important items as you mentioned data
workers human resources and technology
we had a conversation on that with my
colleagues health ministers yesterday
it's going to be these are going to be
key not only in going through the
current omicron crisis but also in terms
of emerging from that crisis and
rebuilding our healthcare system we need
a lot more data for all sorts of reasons
we had we need more workers
health workers are tired exhausted they
have left in large numbers in the
current circumstance they are sick in
very large numbers as well and we need
to make be making better use of
technology some of which we have
developed uh in the in the kobe 19
crisis but some of it we have to develop
as quickly as possible as i said both to
exit and to rebuild uh on from the
crisis
supplementary right
yeah um this one's from mr leblanc you
you mentioned off the top of the
oppressor that
the the federal government's uh
resources are limited that health is a
provincial jurisdiction
um are you telegraphing i guess to
provinces that in terms of their
requests for emergency help like you
received from the bearskin lake
first nation today and i'm sure you'll
receive from other provinces as the week
goes on that there is a limit to what
the federal government can provide and
that
maybe you are hitting that limit
i think what we we've said two things
from the beginning of the pandemic that
obviously the government of canada
will do whatever we can as often as we
can
to support provinces and territories and
indigenous communities so that shouldn't
surprise anyone and i think over the
last 22 months we have worked very
collaboratively with provinces and
territories and indigenous leadership uh
to certainly in an unprecedented way
use the resources of the government of
canada wherever and however we could
bring them to bear in a way to support
provinces and territories
we expect as you noted an increase
uh in the coming weeks
in terms of requests for assistance uh
my colleague jean-yves duclos
patty haidu
bill blair obviously
we're in ongoing and active
conversations with provincial
counterparts and they're saying to us
that we're preparing uh perhaps a
request for assistance in this
particular area or
we're wondering if the government of
canada might support a provincial uh or
indigenous community in another area so
we're moving expeditiously uh to do
obviously everything we can but it's no
surprise that uh provincial and
territorial governments have
considerably more health human resources
for example than with the government of
canada
and that's why we need to be expeditious
and effective in allocating all the
federal resources we can
in a way that most efficiently fills the
gaps that provinces
and territories identify so it's an
ongoing collaborative and we think
positive exercise um but it shouldn't
surprise anybody that
it's not a limitless
number of federal health care resources
that we can bring to bear so our job is
to take absolutely everything we can and
allocate it in the most effective way to
support uh all of our partners to and
canadians to come through the the other
side particularly of this uh urgency
around the omicron variant
operator next question please
the next question is from christy kirkup
from the global mail please go ahead
hello um provinces are imposing
restrictions or lockdown measures uh due
to healthcare capacity and of course
we've seen this a lot in canada and i'm
wondering if this shows that from coast
to coast the capacity of canada's
primary health care system is stretched
too thin and how is the federal
government going to address this
well thank you and i agree with your
statement the capacity is stretched too
thin certainly in the
the current emergency context but more
broadly i think most canadians would
agree that even before corvid 19 our
capacity was often stretched too thin in
particular around this time of the year
when there were other respiratory
diseases and other challenges
uh around the particular season now what
we're doing well what we've done during
the uh with kovin 19 was to invest just
in terms of healthcare a total of 63
billion dollars in addition to all of
the other transfers that were already in
existence before corvid 19. we obviously
provided a lot of support economic
support more than 80 percent of the
total direct assistance to workers and
businesses came from the federal
government and what we have announced in
the campaign was an additional 25
billion dollars to be invested in the
relatively short term to address all
sorts of issues around health and
healthcare but in particular the
healthcare resources issue which is a
tremendous problem across all the the
the country if i may add briefly to what
the minister leblanc said a moment ago
we often think of the canadian air the
canadian armed forces as being a
potential source of important health
care support they have a population of
about 70 000
personnel to serve now 70 000 is about
eight times
less than my own city of quebec quebec
city has eight times more
people than that seventy thousand
personnel that healthcare workers in the
armed forces
need to be looked after so that says
that we have a very limited amount of
health care resources health care health
trained people in the in the caf and
that's why
we have to
answer
in the most appropriate the most focused
in the most equitable manner when uh
requests are made by by provinces for
health care
personnel support what we can do and
what ministry leba also mentioned is to
provide vaccines tests
personal protective equipment we can
provide tracing support
we can provide all sorts of other
non-human
resources
types of assistance this we have done i
think quite successfully and will
continue to do in the long in the short
and the longer term as we do our best
with the kenyan red cross and other
partners to also provide in some
specific context support on healthcare
health related human resources
supplementary christie and
yes thank you and just as a follow-up if
i may um the other day when you
announced the 140 million rapid tests
that will be going out to the provinces
and territories on a per capita basis
i'm wondering i i fully understand that
you have said that the distribution
falls into the realm of the provincial
and territorial governments
but i'm wondering do you have any
concerns about the equity of access
we've seen for example in the province
of ontario people
lining up in minus 20 degrees celsius
for hours on end trying to get access to
rapid tests and i'm just wondering um do
you have any concerns about this and
frankly not a lot of canadians have the
time
maybe um to line up
in frigid cold temperatures to try and
get access to a test that can maybe tell
them if they have cobit 19.
thank you
well on the equity and the efficiency of
the distribution we have four confidence
that provinces and territories will do
what they need to do
to address you know the needs of their
population the prime minister on
wednesday mentioned that again they have
access to more information and to more
networks to distribute those tests in
the most
fair and efficient manner one equity
issue which i would add which you didn't
mention in a question was the equity of
the distribution of rapid tests across
provinces and territories the reason
we're moving to a per capita
formula is that prior to
january
there were provinces and territories
that didn't ask as many rapid tests as
they could have asked based on their per
capita
share of the population so with a per
capita formula we're going to make sure
that every province and every territory
and therefore every person in canada
wherever that pace that person may live
has accessed the same amount of rapid
tests and that again is going to be done
by the
per capita formula
thank you operator uh next uh question
please
i have a question using the reactive
agents used for pcr testing
do you anticipate a shortage of this
we know that the reactive agent is in
high demand
further in a few moments but currently
there is no indication from the
provinces and territories that there is
a request
information i would like doctor new to
respond okay
thank you for the questions
i can tell you that the national
microbiology laboratory in winnipeg has
worked closely
just like before
the national
and territories as needed
requests for assistance how many
provinces and territories have made such
a request
or have indicated that they will make a
request to the federal government
i would like to invite minister leblanc
to answer
more generally and then i will give more
specific information
answers
thank
i think the prime you
and minister blair have said for a long
between time provinces and territories
and the federal government since the
start of the pandemic of course there
are many
uh different circumstances
some of them are not related to the
health crisis don't say demand
uh
is to have these ongoing conversations
very generally speaking
i would like to say that provinces and
territories have
administrations
in early january vaccination rates were
about two million per week and now
we're looking at three million
vaccinations per week
so the rates are not as high as they
were this summer
provinces and territories
the 200.
a hundred other people
are on
and one more thing that i'd like to say
because i was shocked when i heard it
uh when i heard mr o'toole
said which was alluded to by my
colleague
and that is to get all of his members
vaccinated vaccination is the one thing
that will get us out of this crisis and
that will help us fight against the
omicron variant we all have a part to
pay and federal elected officials
next question from
this is very relevant there this is a
question that will come up from the
federal government from the quebec
government i know that the situation is
very difficult there i know it's also
difficult in other provinces
but if i can make a quick aside in the
omicron wave
and they will be challenged in their
ability to provide intensive care
services dr tam was alluding to this
earlier
hospital there are almost 6 000 people
that are hospitalized
many
emphasize vaccination this is true for
mr o'toole and anyone else who still has
doubts about the importance of having
everyone vaccinated
vaccination is what's going to get us
out of us this is what's going to get us
out of this challenge not only in the
short term but in the long term
will continue to be among us there will
be more variants
will continue to be among us for a long
time
the only way to get out
and to get a normal life
we need our children vaccinated we need
people to get booster doses we need to
protect ourselves and to protect our
loved ones
if they don't get vaccinated
i personally think we will get there at
some point
mandatory vaccination
there will always be exceptions
people who have medical reasons to be
exempt
we'll be allowed not to get vaccinated
for
how fragile our health care system is in
canada
our aging population
increasing costs associated with taking
care with everyone i think this type of
measurement
which is not being considered now and we
understand why but it will be a part
what people think about
in provinces and what they think they
could put into their actions we have for
people on the phones reporters in the
room uh we're going to try and land this
in 11 minutes so we'll begin with
creason from ctv please
minister duklow thank you for taking my
question um can you provide any more
details on the help needed for bearskin
lake first nation at least half of the
community of 400 have covered the chief
there is calling for military aid now
for 14 days or longer if needed ontario
has joined in on those calls for
military aid is the federal government
going to answer those calls and can you
provide any timeline on this
well three uh things here first we
and when i say we it includes
my colleagues minister i do and minister
miller um minister blair uh minister
mendicino so all my colleagues are very
mindful of the no the very difficult
challenges that
those communities are facing now
the second thing is that
we have had some
relative success and i i think it's most
people will say that we have had
significant success working with
indigenous communities or with kobe 19
in
in delivering to them the types of
support that they need to look after
their the members of their community and
the third thing is that minister i do in
particular
is in contact every day
with leaders of those of those
communities so that they can provide
they can be provided with the type of
support that the they need and from my
part with the public health agency of
canada we are also working with minister
aidu and her
team and her department to make sure
that they have all the resources the
vaccines the the tests the
the the pb
uh the tracing support the the
expert advice that minister haidu and
her department need to to to look after
indigenous communities and to help them
go through this renewed challenge
so is that a no on military aid so far
not
no decision made on that i would
i would direct you towards minister
blair and mr i do for more specific
information on that
we've got to go to christiana well to
get through four people please so
christian please
subscribe
i
public health
how much strain is on our health care
system we understand that we have to get
out of this situation
the one way to get out of it is to get
vaccinated
rapid testing
distancing pcr tests
all of those are great measures
that's why i see it coming personally
not now i don't think we're there yet
but i think that discussions need to be
have people had about mandatory
vaccination because we need to get rid
of kovid19
you said earlier about rapid testing
that we're doing better than others
how are these preventing you from
telling
in our provinces and
territories at the same time we have to
start having discussions about a longer
term strategy
of course this will be according to
provinces and territories needs
ministries
asking about disparities in provincial
distribution of rapid tests saskatchewan
has gotten twice more than twice as many
tests as manitoba because they had asked
for more you're now shifting the demand
to per capita minister vandell says to
be fair you should balance this out to
make up for provinces that got less so
i'm wondering if you're going to revise
the per capita formula or if manitoba is
going to stay short changed here
well the revision
is started uh
to to to to be in place on january the
1st as of january the 1st our allocation
formula is now a per capita formula so
that we can make sure as you've
correctly
and appropriately mentioned that all
provinces and territories and therefore
everyone in canada has accessed the same
number of tests and that there is there
are no equity issues in terms of
interprovincial considerations okay so
you're not going to make up for that
then
well we always be in in in conversation
with provinces and territories but as i
said we're focusing on the current needs
and the current needs will be addressed
on the per capita
allocation formula
laura osmond cp
thanks ministers i wanted to pick up on
where my colleagues ryan and christy
left off on the sort of finite resources
of the federal government
we've never seen all provinces be so
stressed at the same time we know these
requests are coming we know our
resources are finite so what is the plan
when we simply run out of resources is
it up to provinces to sort of model it
out at that point or
what can you do in the meantime to try
to
fill that gap
you're right uh no the two things on
that first you're correct
the the stress is seen everywhere
second
this being said the stress is being seen
a bit earlier in some provinces than
others and there are two consequences
for that the first one is that ontario
and quebec in particular that's where
the greater stress is currently found
those problems students those two
provinces are going through a very
difficult time
that however is a signal to other
provinces and territories that they may
be just a week perhaps two weeks behind
but they see
and i've i've observed that recent just
yesterday with my colleagues from other
provinces they see what's coming so they
know that public health measures
that everyone understands now will need
to be applied across canada because it's
the same variant across canada so
although you problems may be just a week
or two behind another province in terms
of stress on health care resources
that's coming and sometimes coming very
quickly
so
i'm thinking of
of provinces where the number of
hospitalizations per capita might be
small
slightly smaller now but these provinces
and territories must know and must act
on the basis of what they see
with other provinces like quebec and
ontario
but minister eventually the federal
government's going to
have all of the personnel out that
they're able to offer and the provinces
are still going to be short so what
happens then what is the plan
well as minister leblanc said a moment
ago we'll continue to support provinces
and territories to all possible extent
we've been
quite successful doing this
collaboratively over the last 22 months
and will continue to do that knowing
that
there are some types of support that the
federal government will find harder to
provide because we don't have the
capacity and that's also a warning
uh
a kind warning but a clear warning to
some provinces and territories that they
need to act now
because if they don't act sufficiently
it's going to be difficult for the
federal government to help after because
we don't have the capacity to do so
well everyone is doing their job
and i'm i'm saying that
again based on my conversations with
them yesterday they are acting
and they are right to act and public
health measures are obviously key uh
providing support to businesses and
workers so that
uh lockdowns can be can be applied you
know while taking care of the ability
for everyone to pay for food
so these types of things are
are important you know lockdowns in some
context when we see that the pressure is
going to be too strong for
for in particular our our healthcare
workers
uh minister i think we have just enough
time for creeson's other question and
i'm being asked
for you to repeat in in english your
your view about mandatory vaccines at
some point
uh i believe you may have said that in
french and uh i i just ask you to ponder
that for a second and uh take kristen's
final
question yeah well i can do that and
i'll i'll say two things first it's a
it's a view
which is based on my
personal
understanding of what we see
internationally and domestically and in
my conversations with my colleagues
health ministers over the last few weeks
and second is a decision that will be
made by provinces and territories at
some point whether it be the move
forward or not that's going to be their
decision to make but what we see now is
that our health care system in canada is
fragile
our
our people are tired
um
and
the only way that we know to go through
corvid 19
this variant and any future variant is
through vaccination you know ppe
physical distancing
tests rapid tests pcr tests these are
all very important tools but what will
make us move through this crisis and end
it is vaccination and i see in my own
province
uh
50 percent of
hospitalizations now in quebec
are due to people not having been
vaccinated that's a burden on health
care workers a burden on society which
is very difficult to
to bear and for many people difficult to
understand so that's why i'm signaling
this as a as a as a conversation which i
believe provinces and territories in
support with the federal government will
want to have over the next
weeks and months
really appreciate that and we'll end
with uh creason's final question there
minister duklow erin o'toole said the
unvaccinated should be accommodated
through measures like rapid testing
testing what do you think should happen
in this regard
um can you i was just slightly
distracted no that's okay aaron o'toole
said the unvaccinated should be
accommodated through measures like rapid
testing what do you think should happen
in this regard
rapid tests are not going to end the
crisis rapid tests are not going to
solve kobe 19.
the only thing that will solve kobe 19
is vaccination and that's why again
so many people including myself
are disturbed by the fact that minister
mr o'toole is not even asking is all
members of parliament to be vaccinated
that's
that's i don't understand and i think
all
no health expert understands and most
canadians don't understand no the only
way to end this crisis is to be
vaccinated
other tools are important but mr o'toole
should ask his members of parliament his
caucus members to be vaccinated that
would be a sign of leadership on his
part
and
before we end
uh i just think
i know that in french and quebec in
particular
in the last few years
irresponsible and inexcusable
yeah
as of wednesday
27 of the 130
passengers have been have arrived back
in canada they took four different
flights
they were messed up
pcr
contact information for these travelers
to make sure
that they are following their quarantine
plans
so their files
have been referred to the
because this is provincial
jurisdiction and they will have to
follow up on these
health rules but there are also
transport canada rules if we see the
images
that were shared
transport canada rules were broken
so there you go because sun wing has
been such a cast celeb across the
country if you could uh share your
thoughts on that in english as well
because i think i heard some news there
okay so i'll try to do that in my best
english
um
and so first i i we hear and we know
that this uh
issue of songwing uh travelers
uh having behaved irresponsibly
inexcusably
and
unacceptably on a flight to mexico that
has raised a lot of anger and
frustration as the prime minister said
just two days ago on the part of many
canadians
recent information that we were given
indicates that about 27 out of these
approximately 130 passengers have now
returned to canada on wednesday they
were all stopped and
interrogated at the
air
border
they were then all tested
they were checked
in with regards to
whether they had
obeyed and followed all of the health
regulations that they were supposed to
follow throughout their trip in
particular regarding their proof of
vaccination the
the quality the integrity of their pcr
test their quarantine
plan were also inspected the
and all of that was uh correlated with
the information that they had entered
into arrive can which is an essential
tool for all travelers uh entering
canada
quebec which is the
provincial
police
department proactively contacted the
public health agency of canada to
seek
information on those travelers
the
the contravention contravention files
that were issued uh for some of these
travelers were sent to the government of
quebec through their legal
authority and team and that's in
addition to the ongoing investigation
and possible possible prosecution that
transport canada and other agencies uh
will will continue to uh to pursue
minister i really appreciate your
briefing uh today doctors thank you
thank you to mr leblanc moncton and this
completes
this news conference and briefing from
the parliamentary precinct in downtown
ottawa
you